hi everyone my name is elite amagashi
from the naguchi memorial institute for
medical research in ghana
and i'm presenting on the topic effects
of circulating pfcsb variants which is
thus modern positive prime
variants in ghana and the application on
western development my supervisors are
dr anita ganza from nuguchi memorial
institute and doctor lia elia broski of
the pine biotech team
malaya remains of major public health
concern
and so therefore we need a vessel
however the major challenge of
development of successful malaria
vessels is the issue of antigenic
diversity of malaria vision candidates
antigens and natural parasite
populations
meanwhile currently the most advanced
version is the ltss aso1 business
designed based on the immunogenic
regions of plasmodium fossil from
surface protozoa person 3d7 laboratory
strain which is the reference string
this vessel is made up of parts of the
essential repeat region of pfcsp
and the c-terminal region of dental and
entire c-seminar region fused with
hepatitis b antigen to boost immunity
in the c terminal region are polymorphic
cd4 and cd8
um
immunodominant epitopes
and this vason
has
which includes
which is included in the vessel
construct
however the degree of malaria
transmission intensity in previous
studies has been shown to affect the
extent of genetic diversity of pfcsp
whereby diverse psesp pscsp non-vascular
hypertypes
in specific immune epitopes of pfcsv
antigen has been detected reflected in
low levels of 3d7 strain in ghanaian
natural parasite population
another study has also
confirmed that there has been poor
vastness efficacy against non-western
3d7 parasite strains
therefore
our study
determines to
seek um
know the effects of these changes on of
these changes which are those variations
at the specific t-cell epitopes on
protein structure in this interactions
and because this um changes all these
effects are poorly understood
therefore we study the
genetic diversity of pfcsb between two
distinct ecological regions in ghana and
the impact of this amino acid especially
amino acid mutations specifically in the
immunodominant epitopes on structure
stability and potentially its effect on
t-cell mediated immunity
a study was conducted at two sites with
variable malaria transmission
intensities which is calculated using
the entomological inoculation rate erl
which refers to the number of effective
bytes of mosquito per person per year
looking at the two sites we looked at
cape coast which has an erl of 50
effective buy per person per year and in
avrongo we have
1132 effective bytes per person per year
so clearly you can see there's a vast
difference in malaria transmission
intensities between the two sites
in cape cod
we collected 184 immunohigh
sequence data generated from the
gucci lab and also in navrango we had
one 256 illumina high six data
and it went through this pipeline
whereby um sequences were aligned and
variant analysis was done using cluster
w and also we determined patterns of
amino acid sequence substitution
and their frequencies within each
population in r
we also feather went ahead to do
entropy based conservation analysis
whereby we
mapped on um the mutations onto the
structure
to determine if these mutations are
being seen at our
dominant epitopes
further to determine um or to predict
the impact of this mutations at this
t-cell epitopes we went ahead to do um
prediction analysis and mutation effects
prediction analysis using the dynamic
rule to determine if
the mutations would destabilize the
protein or preserve a structure
the result overall
and with the distribution of the amino
acid mutations
the results revealed that um the two
geographical
distinct ghanaian parasite population
which is cape cod and navrango had
varying levels of polymorphisms at
similar positions
and we also saw that there were some
positions that had similar mutable
positions which are 314 321 through 224
327 at the th2r epitope and 352 359 at
the time
when we look at table 1 and table 2.
we also saw some common mutations
and seen
in our population between the both
populations um example such as a
mutation from k to q and the
three-photon position
shows that um
we're seeing in both populations
and
etc when you look at the um the table
we also saw some mutations were more
prevalent in navranga than in cape coast
example k314
ql327i and 3359 tn
we also observed some mutations where
sin olin and capros and others were also
saying pulling and navron go we observe
the table one and two we also observed
some mutations had highest mutation
rates
than even the reference um
amino acid example
k317a was observed in 78.1 percent of
the population and n321k
um was observed in about 77.4
um
0.4 percent in the
population also a blue substitutes cause
which is done to determine how frequent
these mutations are in our population
reveal positive a lot of positive scores
positive scores shows that um these
mutations occur frequently are likely to
occur frequently in the population
um these mutations are likely to
substitute frequently
um and a negative score shows that these
mutations are likely to substitute
rarely
we saw um a lot of positive um um
lessons cost but then we saw about two
mutations that um had negative scores
and ensures that they are likely to
occur really
also position based conservation
analysis um confirmed that
most of the mutations are
being seen and the th2r and three are
immunodominant regions in both and
parasite populations keep causing
everyone also the mutation effects
prediction which is to determine
um but before then the phytochemical um
properties
shows that most of the mutations
had radical replacements whereby most of
the mutations
were seen to change from one
phytochemical chemical property to the
other
we also saw
that
um to determine if this fight um changes
in the mutations with stabilizing
protein or preservatives we saw eight
mutations having destabilizing effect on
the protein thereby um affecting t cell
recognition
generally at the end of the study we
we observed that um the minor acid
mutations has previously reported a t
cell epitopes may alter structural
conformation and consequently compromise
holds um immune recognition to t-cells
and
looking at what happened in ancillary
studies by nucleo which shows that
vasan efficacy tended to decrease with
the number of mismatches at d7 positions
which is 299 301 317 354 35639 and 361
in our study in the ghanian population
we are seeing changes at this also also
at this positions which is three zero
one three seventeen three fifty four
three forty six and two groups of nine
also we showed we also
um observed that there were more uh
mutations increased mutations in
narendra than in cod and we attribute
that to the um
higher malaria transmission patterns
that has been observed between the two
populations
this
the study also gives us insight into
knowing that we need to include
um or detect geographical differences in
amino acids even within the same country
and this should provide insights into
the need to design
location specific malaria vessels
um radical replacement as seen with the
changes in phytochemical properties
um between the two um
of amino acids shows
a replacement from hydrophobic to
hydrophilic residues when in terms of
hydropathy and chemistry we have changes
in terms of chemistry we've seen changes
between basic to acidic
basic to a mine etc when you look at
table three
we also observed that um
likely this
changes that we are seeing
may alter the confirmation of the
protein structure with the potential of
affecting instability that is why we
went ahead to do the mutation prediction
analysis which shows that about eight
mutations are predicted to be
destabilizing and therefore when um
we are being infected with the parasites
your immune system may evade it
in navrongo we also observed that there
were some negative blossoms caused in
the changes with amino acid specific
positions and this shows that this
substitutions occur really and might be
selected against
overall
um this study um emphasizes the need to
frequently
monitor um
diversity in our populations and to
probably include the most frequent amino
acid substitutions
into making a polyvalent vessel
therefore aside from the wild type we
need to include
this mutant to to the western component
also considering the extent of diversity
in the circulating parasites from
different transmission settings is
important and can provide us with
insight as to how well the ltss es01 was
underperformed when implemented in ghana
and alaska thank you very much